Hong Kong bustles at any time of year,...
...but the Mid-Autumn Festival brings out the best and brightest of this vibrant city.
The celebration is also known as the Moon Festival,...
...and the traditional dessert is exchanged as holiday gifts.
Modern mooncakes come in all shapes and flavors,...
...but purists prefer thin-crusted cakes made with lotus seed paste...
...and salted egg yolks that symbolize the full moon.
Chinese lanterns are also integral to the party atmosphere.
Local artist and master Chan creates festive masterpieces with nothing more than bamboo,...
...colored paper and a fertile imagination.
For kids, the festival's a chance to stay up late...
...and marvel at the citywide display of lanterns.
The fire dragon dances are arguably the hottest attraction of the entire festival.
The 220-foot-long dragon winds its way through the Tai Hang neighborhood...
...amid much fanfare and scented smoke.
The three-day dance was originally performed to drive plague from Tang Hai in the 19th century.
It's noisy and it's smoky, but this holiday will not fail to ignite all your senses.